gemma how you doing samuel leaves
great to talk to you fabulous work on
all your
crazy viewings and activity and um
with your questions yeah great
that you had i just figured that i'd
probably be a good person to speak to
about this because
it's really really my back so yeah um
so yeah well just just remind me what
what's the situation there so you
basically you've had an offer
exceptional property
you're you're emailing out you've got
lots of interested investors but they're
all asking for
um they're all asking for mbas
yeah so um
so i'm actually sourcing to what they
are wanting yes so i went out on monday
um and found a really great property in
gainsborough
which could be a potential hmo
so um i made an offer it got accepted
and i've been sending things out to
people
and then people are coming back saying
they want more information what streets
it
it's on what um what's the other the
areas like
have you got any comparables and loads
of information really and i'm like
i'm sure we don't get to that stage
until
yeah you know you give me that that
thing and then we go and talk about it
because
if i've got like 20 people constantly
asking me those questions
like times times money isn't it exactly
exactly
one person that's seriously watching so
many videos
because otherwise you'll get a busy form
answering 100 investors questions
they'll ask you a hundred questions each
and then now
and then they'll say can i go and view
it and then i'll go and view it and then
i'll say now
let me let me think about it let me talk
to my wife let me talk to my dog let me
talk to my lawyer that we talked about i
know
and they will waste your time like crazy
so so
okay the first thing that you need to be
doing when you email out a deal and you
have someone call you up
you need to be making sure that you're
asking them the questions and you're
taking control of the situation right
from the get-go so
let me roll play with you real quick
right now and
i'll be you and you'll be the investor
and i'll tell you what i would what how
i would how i would control because a
lot of it is not about
paperwork and mdas a lot of it is about
just how you have that initial call in
the first place and setting the
expectations
so let's run it i mean that's where i go
wrong
okay but for sure that's correct but
then you send an email with d
and then and then presumably that email
turns into a phone call or not
it did last night
you've been on the phone and a half and
you say he's buying
[Music]
okay that was fine that's fine okay so
um
in fact let me just see what you're
saying so you send an email with all the
figures
bang bang bang with the area let me i'll
be the
i'll be the investor okay so i'll i'll
message you and i'll say yeah i'm really
interested
and then and then we jump on a call
together because that's that's the
protocol so you send an email
the call to action should be send me an
email back
if you if you want to reserve it and
then we'll jump on a call
and we'll go through the next step
that's kind of the the protocol
so then straight away you're saying to
people
send me an email if you want to reserve
it and then we'll jump on a call and
we'll go through the next step so you
you're trying to
filter out the time wasters right from
the get-go
then you jump on the call you jump on
the call let's jump on a call right now
so i'll be the investor
hey jenna the property looks great um
what
what's the uh what's the address
okay so um i mean i don't
i don't actually give out the addresses
to start off with usually that's the
next step
okay
okay so i mean obviously before i start
signing terms and conditions and paying
fees i need to know
i need to know about the property so i
you know you've said you've negotiated
for 82 000
but what's the market value and what
comparables can i see to demonstrate
that
right okay well um having been in the
area
and i know the area quite well this
street is actually a very long stream
the comparables of recent days of the
study
has not it's not really a true
reflection of what the property is
itself but i do have similar properties
and that you know i'll be happy to
discuss with you
[Music]
this is where this is where what's
happening i can see why you're running
into difficulties so basically what's
happening is the investors ringing you
up and asking you a load of questions
and you're the person
you're you're answering their questions
you're assisting them you're working
with them
that is not how the conversation goes
this is how the conversation goes so
let's flip around now the other way
around and you can bring me up and i'll
do exactly what i do word-for-word so um
yeah okay um
hello
yeah sure listen i'm very happy to talk
all about the property in specifics but
before we do that would it be okay if i
ask you a couple of questions about the
situation
just to see if this would be a good fit
brilliant
okay what would you like to know okay
cool so i mean firstly are you in a
position where you're actually ready to
buy or are you just browsing at the
moment
okay okay excellent
um and also because i mean this this
property you know i've secured it i've
got the agent breathing down my neck
so of course i'm happy to give you all
the details and particulars but
it needs to go in the next 24 hours so
are you
saying you're in a position to go and to
move have you got the funds in place
um
excellent and also assuming that the
property is right and assume that it
fits the
bill for you and it fits your criteria
and it's the kind of property you want
to buy
um are you in a position where you can
pay the finance fee today
[Music]
i have secured it i've got a really good
price on it and the agent is
breathing down my neck at the moment
asking me to provide the the proof of
funds the deposit and all these
particulars
i've got a lot of investors on my list
at the moment i've got like 70 80
investors
and i've got quite a few people to speak
to so i mean as i say i'm very happy to
give you all
all the big details and particulars but
before i do that i need to know that you
are ready to move
so if the property was right and if it
ticked all the boxes and it was it was
and it was
you know it worked for you would you
would you be in a position where you'd
be able to pay a fee today or is that
little would that be a little bit too
quick for you at the moment because if
you're too quick that's absolutely fine
we can always
touch base with another property maybe
the next couple of weeks
i'm very happy to give you all the
details that you need
but i'm only because this probably has
to move quickly i don't want to waste
your time and waste my time so i'm only
looking to work with somebody
that's that's prepared to you know put
down something today to secure it so we
can get this all wrapped up
that was brilliant was that helpful yeah
yeah so what's going on
and if it's right would you be able to
put down something today to secure it if
they if they want to say yes to that i
am not giving them anything i'm not even
giving them the city it's in like they
are getting
this deadly squat if they say to me yeah
you know what if it ticks the boxes and
if it's right
i would give you a fee today great
that's awesome and then
i'll move to stage two but i think that
stage one is where you were getting
stuck
and that stage one is where um i feel
like i give them enough
already listen don't talk to someone
don't talk just don't don't don't waste
your time having a conversation with
someone if they're not
listen if they're not going to pay you a
fee today even if it's the best property
in the world but no
they have to think about it and get they
get their stuff together and their
finances on there
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna answer one
single question
yeah so it's about qualifying and it's
about taking control of the conversation
right at the very beginning
look i'm very happy to to give you all
the information you need what was it
that caught your eye about the property
okay cool
and are you in a position to move now oh
right and obviously you saw there's a
three thousand pound fee
assuming the property is right and if it
ticks the boxes for you would you be
able to pay that
um three thousand pounds a day and then
if they're not if they're saying yes yes
yes yes i would i would have would then
go great so what is it that you need to
know about the property what do you need
what do you need to know obviously
you've seen the email
you've seen that it's 80 000 pounds it's
worth 100 000 the rent 6q5 i've got an
agent nearby blah blah blah
so what what do you need to know for me
right now in order to make a decision
now if the investor um
genuinely is like look man i just i just
want to see before i pay any money i
just want to see the details myself
you could either you could send them an
ndi i'm happy to send you over in ndi
um but i wouldn't send them an nd unless
they've answered yes yes yes those
questions and i wouldn't send them an
ndi unless they showed me
that their money in their bank first
because otherwise you'll be sending out
ndas to 100 people and they're all going
to be losing
like this exactly so i'd only be sending
an nda to somebody if they're
absolutely ready to go they're serious
we've got money in the bank and they've
agreed in principle but they just want a
couple hours or whatever
to look over look over the details
they're fine i'll give an idea what i
don't want to do generally i normally
say
listen what do you need to know for me
to make a decision okay i'll answer all
the
i'll answer all their questions and then
i'll say is there anything else you need
to know
i just want to just check over the
figures like okay cool listen
if everything i've said is correct again
it would if everything i've said is
correct
would you you know would you like to go
ahead and go yeah i would
i would assuming everything you said
it's correct they're okay how about this
i'll send you over to t's and c's
uh sorry to get those signed then i'll
send you an invoice for 3 000 pounds get
that paid and then i'll give you
14 days to do all the due diligence you
want
and if in those 14 days anything i've
said to you is incorrect
or there's any issues you can have that
money back however
if after 14 days you just change your
mind due to no fault of the property or
no issues with the property just because
you can't get your stuff together
then there's no refund included okay
so there's different avenues but the key
thing is
to qualify them when they really qualify
them ask
questions take control don't deal with
time wasters
and um and then qualify them before you
give them any information whatsoever and
only be dealing with people who've got
the money
okay so the main questions are are you
in a position to move today
yep and you're doing it because if you
said to someone
are you going to just do it today
they'll go all right depends depends on
the property so you can say
if the property is perfect it takes all
the boxes for you
would you be in a position where you can
where you can secure it today and move
quickly
and then they can't and if they want to
say yes to that even if the property is
perfect for them they still won't be
able to move today then why are we on
the phone because this this property
needs to go today
and i've got another 78 investors that i
can be speaking with so
and then i'm not going to be nasty to
you i'm going to say look um well i
think probably makes sense
is if they're not ready by the way
because you don't want to burn bridges
or tick anybody off or off anymore
so if they're not quite ready i'll just
say to them listen this particular
property it's a really good deal and it
needs to go today i've got the agent
breathing down my neck however
when you're in a position whereby you
can move a bit quicker
um or if you see another property down
the line give me a call back let's stay
in touch and you leave the door open but
you get off that freaking phone
yes yeah awesome
yeah it really really helps that does
because i thought
i felt like compelled to give them more
information i don't would be nothing big
for my biggest because i'm
still early days in my
sourcing experience i mean property
investing kind of got that sort of
in the card i've been financing since i
was 21.
this is the sourcing side and delivering
to potential investors and
because my investors are so small and
i've
[Music]
if you if what you're doing is every
time you speak to an investor and you
turn them down
you're training them on expectations if
you let investors walk all over you
you're training them that's okay
and then next time they die they'll walk
the same they're all the same so
so you know and what you'll start doing
is you'll start having investors contact
you and you'll go sorry i just sold that
deal three minutes ago
or someone would go i'll think about it
i'll get back to you tomorrow and you go
okay
call me back tomorrow then but i'm not
gonna have to hold it because it's first
come first serve
then tomorrow they'll call you back and
go i want to do it you'll go sorry it's
old and you're creating that reputation
and training your investors but let me
know how you get on
yeah let me know how you get on and if
you need any further help or anything
just jump on a call